let's start with the big question
who is God
according to Christianity according to
Catholicism who's God I'll give you
Thomas acquaintance definition uh God is
ipsum essay subsistence God is the
subsistent act of 2B itself
another way to state that in Aquinas is
God is that reality unique absolutely
unique
in which Essence and existence coincide
to be God is to be to be those are all
ways of talking about what we mean by
God they are kind of nomic and and
that's on purpose there's almost a Zen
koan kind of quality about the way we
talk about God
I'm saying something that's substantive
but it's more in like a via negativa
mode it's more like what God is not
because there's nothing in the world
that would correspond to those
descriptions so anything in the world
would be a being of some type or an
event of some type some particular mode
of existence
and God is not an entity
in the world in fact I would say that's
the fundamental mistake that atheists
old and new make all the time is they
think of God
as a big being
when Aquinas says that God is not in any
genus even the genus of being it's one
of the strangest remarks in the whole
tradition but it's really interesting so
you say well at the very least God must
be a being right and aquinas's answer is
no he's not in the genus of being so we
talk about God being Beyond being and so
on
to say in God Essence and existence
coincide is to say God's very nature is
to be and that can't be true of any
contingent thing in the world
so what I'm doing there is I'm I'm
gesturing the way the tradition does
toward God using language that's at the
same time
philosophically precise and nomic you
know it's both accurate it's true in God
Essence and existence coincide what God
is is the same as God's uh active to be
but now what does that mean I'm not
quite sure because nothing in our
ordinary experience corresponds to that
everything in our experience is is a
being of some type so it's existence
received according to the mode of some
essence
that's not true of God
which is why you can't be found in the
world and and that's as I say
the fundamental mistake is uh oh I guess
theists are those that believe there's
this being alongside the other beings in
the universe and then atheists say oh no
there is no such being
um and that's precisely wrong that's
just a category error
Dawkins I think cites Bertrand Russell
to the effect that proving the
non-existence of God is a bit like
proving the non-existence of a China
teapot orbiting between Earth and Mars
you know no that's precisely what God is
not some entity that's sort of hidden
among the other entities of the universe
God is the reason why there's a
contingent realm at all this is the way
to put it a more theological language
God's the creator of all things so if
God is outside of our world is it
possible for us to visualize to
comprehend to know God not utterly of
course and I would say our knowledge
begins always in this world begins in
ordinary experience but I think we can
through metaphysical analysis through
philosophical reasoning can come to some
knowledge of a reality which is
transcendent to our experience so we
gesture toward it I always like Aquinas
who says the language about God that we
use as analogical
so it's not it's not univocal meaning
what I say about that you know can or
about this bottle I can say about God no
that makes God an entity at the same
time it's not simply equivocal
so if I say well that thing is and God
is I mean totally different things no no
I mean something analogous so to be God
is to be to be so the real meaning of
being is the being of God the being of
that thing or this thing or the being of
galaxies or subatomic particles would be
analogous to God's manner of being
so on that basis I can make some
statements I can
I can theorize and even at the limit as
you suggest I can visualize so we have
metaphors for God and the Bible is
replete with those right so God is a
rock uh you know God's like a lion God's
like this and that or the Bible will
sometimes imagine God as a as a human
being walking around you know now only
the crude is fundamentalism would say
well that's a unificable accurate
description of God it's an image that's
catching something of God's manner of
being
then what does it mean to believe in God
so there's a word and we'll have to
limit ourselves to human interpretive
awards today there's a word called Faith
what does faith mean so if we can't
really directly know God
you kind of sneak up
to the idea of God with metaphors better
he sneaks up on us because I like the
language of Grace God's action comes
first so if I stay perfectly within the
realm of I'm seeking with my kind of
eagle eyes and my inquiring mind I'm not
going to find God that way I I might
find a path that opens up but I would
say finally God finds me and I think
then the language of Faith begins to
make more sense
um I'm with Paul tillich though the
Protestant Theologian so the most
misunderstood word in the religious
vocabulary is Faith because he said the
way we take it usually is something
sub-rational you know I have I have uh
proof of this I I really know this and I
only kind of believe that like that's
just a personal opinion or impression
but that's to identify
Faith with the kind of infra-rational
and and that's not it I mean I don't
want something infra-rational I don't
want Superstition or or childish
credulity so authentic faith
is is the darkness Beyond Reason and on
the far side of reason it's it's super
irrational not infra-rational and that's
a very important move
at the limit of what I can know at the
limit of my striving and my vision
there's this Horizon that opens up and I
think that's true even in ordinary ways
of knowing there's a kind of a horizon
that lures us beyond what I've got faith
has to do more with that kind of
Darkness rather than a Darkness prior to
reason
the darkness Beyond the Horizon prior to
reason first of all the Poetry language
is incredible to be to be you have a
million questions yeah go ahead I do too
uh so first of all let me just jump
around uh you mentioned to be to be a
few times yeah what does that mean well
to be me is to be a human being right to
be this to be a table to be this would
be a microphone so it's I'll use
aquinas's language it's the act of being
poured if you want into the receptacle
of some essential principle so it's got
a ontological structure it's it's an
existent it's a thing that exists but
it's it's existing in a limited way
according to an essential principle
uh God said well who what's God what's
God's name what kind of being is he
we'll go back to Moses now
um when the Israelites ask me you know
what's your name what shall I tell them
and he says you know famously I am who I
am but see Aquinas reads that as a very
accurate remark so Moses is wondering
okay there's a lot of gods and there's a
lot of things a lot of entities which
one are you you got to be one of them so
tell me your name in philosophical
language give me the essence that
receives your act of existing right
and God's answer blows the mind of of
Moses and the whole tradition I am who I
am to be God is to be
so I'm not this or that I'm not up or
down I'm not here or there God is that
whose Center is every word whose
circumference is nowhere as as the
mystics put in now can I get a clear and
distinct idea of that no and in a way
that's the whole point if I could I'd be
talking about a being of some kind
so to be God is to be to be is to and
that's you know Moses take off your
sandals you're on Holy Ground so I'm
going to go over confidently and find
out what this thing is this Burning Bush
I'm going to find out
no no
take off your shoes you're on Holy
Ground because you're not in charge here
you're not in command because if you got
shoes on
you can walk wherever you want you can
walk with confidence but you take your
shoes off you're much more vulnerable uh
and that's appropriate when you're
talking about God you know but here's
another interesting but I didn't think
about the burning bush in in this
connection before but
it's a bush that's on fire but not
consumed
is beings are competitive with each
other and so I these can't be in the
same place at the same time these two
beings they're mutually exclusive if you
want
But as God comes close to a creature
he doesn't destroy it or consume it but
the creature becomes more beautiful and
more radiant right but and see compare
it to the to the classical gods and
goddesses when when they come bursting
into life and experience things are
incinerated and people give way and
they're overwhelmed then there's this
biblical idea of God comes close and
sets things on fire but doesn't burn
them up
and that's because he's not a
competitive being in the world if he
were a big being then he'd be in this
he'd be competing for space so to speak
on the same ontological grid
but he's not like that
so God can come close
and we come more Fully Alive now we're
starting to gesture toward the
Incarnation I mean the Central Christian
doctrine that God can actually become a
human
without overwhelming the human he
becomes right so I mean that's that's
kind of The Next Step but the basic idea
of God is non-competitively transcendent
to the world that's another way to get
at it
non-competitively Transcendent to the
world so it's beyond being is the source
of being right
let me make it maybe more more imagistic
I think a really good analogy would be
author to book right so
uh like Tolkien or someone that writes
one of these you know big sprawling
novels and tolkien's good too because he
creates a whole world he creates a new
nature a new language new history all
that think of you know the thousands of
characters and the plots and subplots
and all of it
Tolkien is utterly responsible for every
bit of that story right every character
every plot every subplot every
description he's completely responsible
he's involved in every nook and cranny
of it
but he's not in the story he's not in
the book you're not going to find him as
a character in the book so that's the
category mistake of the atheist in a way
is I'm looking for God he's a character
in this story somewhere no he's the
author of the story
mysteriously present to every aspect of
the story but not a character in it
right he is deeply in the story somehow
he's present but he's not
um even if he is a character he's not
really the full embodiment is not a
character and people inside
the book can't really know about the
author because right no right well see
Augustine says God is simultaneously in
Timmy or intimo Mayo at Superior sumomeo
he's closer to me than I am to myself
and he's higher than anything I could
possibly imagine at the same time but
see once you get the the Insight that
God is is the sheer Act of to be well of
course that's true so right now God is
sustaining Us in existence true
Aquinas says God is in all things by
Essence presence and power and most
intimately so
and
and he's nowhere in this room okay well
where's God he's nowhere in this room
he's totally Terror Ali Terror we say
he's totally other
same time but once you crack that code
though I think you see it of like why
that would be true you see now I'm
getting from more philosophical language
to more mystical language because all
the mystics talk that way in these high
paradoxes about God's availability and
unavailability
I I I've often thought in the Bible
story after Story God can neither be
grasped
nor hidden from
so the the first sinful instinct is to
grasp at God's I've got him I've I
understand him I can I can manipulate
him no no it's story after Story is told
you can't do that well then the other
extreme of The Sinner all right then I'm
gonna I'm gonna run from God I'm gonna
avoid God
Jonah and the whale you know so he he
has the call from God and he said no no
I'm gonna refuse that I'm gonna run as
far away I'm gonna go to tarshish which
meant like Timbuktu for them at the end
of the world
God's got the whale swallows him up and
brings him right back where God wants
them it's a you know poetic way of
saying you can't escape the Press of God
at the same time Tower Babble I'm going
to build the Tower up to God I'm gonna
I'm gonna grab hold of God no no he
can't tell you
so live in the space in between those
two things which would be the space of
Friendship with God uh
falling in love with God is neither
grasping nor hiding from God